des soins ici on trie les denrées
alimentaires on les organise puis on en
reçoit davantage
c'est une vraie fourmilière
car ces provisions doivent s'envoler
rapidement pour aider les sinistrés des
inondations et les communautés
autochtones isolées
une grande opération logistique possible
grâce à chandra des ips propriétaire du
club d'aviation ouest cause par le club
un ami et moi sommes partis survoler les
régions éloignées quand les inondations
ont commencé on a vu des gens en
détresse ont atterri pour les aider le
constat sur le terrain et l'a poussé à
continuer
il a contacté des amis propriétaires
d'avions pour solliciter leur aide de
bouche à oreille en moins de deux
semaines
l'aviateur à constituer une flotte de 55
avions et cinq hélicoptères
et qui dit plus d'avions diplôme de
pilote l'aviateur peut compter sur des
amis des bénévoles comme samuel daigle
j'ai les compétences et les invités pour
le faire donc pourquoi pas
[Musique]
il a même eu besoin de louis un deuxième
hangar
si les avions sont prêtés que les
provisions sont offerts généreusement et
qu'une armée de bénévoles est au rendez
vous il reste à payer l'essence
mais cartes de crédit sont pleines j'ai
payé plus de 15000 dollars on reçoit des
dons en argent mais ça ne couvre pas
tout le seul déplacement de deux heures
en hélicoptère peut coûter jusqu'à 700
dollars
chan ancien pompier aime visiblement
toujours éteindre des feux
plusieurs ici comme samuel déplore le
manque de soutien des gouvernements son
peuple de rock n'roll
un constat partagé par chambre
justin trudeau est allé dans ces
communautés autochtones isolées la
semaine dernière avec trois hélicoptères
sans provision mais remplie de
journalistes
en survolant la région on constate bien
les défis les routes sont parfois
accidenté d'autres fermé ou sont à
risque de glissement de terrain
nous voilà arrivés à boston beurre dans
la vallée du fraser quand lee thompson
travaille pour le service des incendies
du coin et elle distribue aux familles
les provisions généreusement livry
la femme est époustouflé par toute cette
solidarité et les moins loquace
lorsqu'on lui demande de qualifier
l'aide reçue du gouvernement
heureusement que changer son équipe sont
là dit elle l'art est dure quelques
minutes à peine
car d'autres attendent oiseaux comme un
ange venu du ciel ici et les acer et
radio canada l'anglais